vamos a seguir trabajando con esta idea
visual de cómo representar una
multiplicación de fracciones así que
para esto déjenme tomarme un medio un
medio y multiplicarlo lo voy a
multiplicar por algo sencillo para
empezar lo voy a multiplicar por un
cuarto
no voy a multiplicar por un cuarto ahora
antes de que me digas la respuesta vamos
a intentar verlos de una manera visual
así que para esto déjenme hacer aquí
un entero voy a tomarme a este entero y
vamos a dividir lo primero en cuatro
partes iguales y para dividirlo en
cuatro partes iguales
y recuerda que esto es la la parte más
difícil de todo el vídeo e intentaré que
sea aquí aquí y aquí bien voy a decir
que estas son las cuatro partes iguales
y yo lo que quiero es tomarme una de
estas cuatro partes que tengo aquí en mi
entero me voy a tomar un cuarto un
cuarto de este entero representan ok voy
a traer esta herramienta representa
tomarme o espera espera déjame cambiar
de r
representa tomarme esta parte de aquí me
estoy tomando una cuarta parte una
cuarta parte de todo este entero que
tengo aquí por lo tanto de estas cuatro
partes solamente voy a dibujar voy a
colorear una de ellas está ok ahora de
estas cuatro partes que representa tener
un medio multiplicando a un cuarto y
bueno como aquí lo que quiero hacer es
tomarme un medio de este cuarto que
tengo ya aquí que te parece si divido
ahora todo el entero voy a dividir ahora
a todo el entero a la mitad
voy a dividirlo pero ahora verticalmente
voy a dividirlo a la mitad o espera
espera no quería hacer esto déjame
cambiar a esta herramienta y lo voy a
dividir a la mitad ok ahora estás
dividir a la mitad y si yo me quiero
tomar un medio de un cuarto lo que
quiere decir es que me voy a tomar la
mitad de este cuarto por lo tanto
solamente voy a colorear como resultado
parte de arriba solamente voy a colorear
a la mitad de este cuarto
es decir voy a colorear a esta parte de
aquí esta parte de aquí representa a un
medio por un cuarto es decir la mitad de
un cuarto ahora si te das cuenta déjame
que me da herramientas voy a poner a con
este color cuando este color
esto representa uno solamente uno de los
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho de los ocho pedazos que tengo de
este entero es decir me estoy tomando un
octavo un octavo de la mitad de un
cuarto solamente hay uno de color
amarillo de todos estos ocho que tengo
en total por lo tanto puedo decir que un
medio por un cuarto es un octavo y eso
lo podemos verificar de una manera
matemática uno por uno es uno ok y abajo
me quedaría dos por cuatro lo cual es
ocho de lujo llegamos a la respuesta
correcta ahora ya que tengo este ejemplo
que estaba bastante tranquilo vamos
un ejemplo un poco más difícil se me
ocurre esta vez trabajar con a dos
tercios dos tercios ya esto lo voy a
multiplicar lo voy a multiplicar por
cuatro quintos no voy a multiplicar por
cuatro quintos ok y voy a seguir esta
misma idea visual así que para eso
déjame hacer aquí ambiente no me voy a
tomar aquí a un entero pero esta vez muy
de tomar un entero más o menos así ya
esté entero lo voy a dividir primero en
cinco partes iguales así que intentamos
hacerlo a una parte una parte ok
a dos partes aunque hay dos partes que
tres partes tres partes okay más o menos
sí y cuatro partes cuatro partes
ok y tengo una dos tres cuatro o cinco
perfecto tengo a este entero dividido en
cinco partes iguales de lujo ahora de
estas cinco partes iguales me quiero
tomar cuatro de ellas cuatro quintos por
lo tanto vamos a cambiar a esta
herramienta y vamos a colorear cuatro
quintas partes de este entero así que
cambiemos la herramienta esta
herramienta no me sirve
voy a colorear cuatro quintas partes
aquí tengo la primera una uno que está
un poco largo esto veamos algo así
porque algo así que esta es la parte
tardado del vídeo y además que es
bastante difícil lograr que me queden
partes muy parecidas partes casi iguales
así que aquí tengo una aquí tengo la
otra dibujada
otra coloreada coloreada ok más o menos
así ok no soy un gran dibujante ni
coloreo de la manera más perfecta pero
creo que se entiende el punto aquí aquí
la otra ok entonces vamos a hacerlo tal
vez un poco más rápido algo más o menos
así más o menos así ok
algo como por acá vamos bien vamos bien
vamos hablar un poquito más de color ok
ok y pues son cuatro entonces me falta
una ahora o no no ya me pase o no no no
vamos a hacer la última atrás la vamos
rápido vamos metiendo la velocidad
ok más o menos así más o menos así
ok me pase tantito pero bueno uno no
puede ser perfecto en esta vida o bueno
al menos lo intenta a ok más o menos así
ok ok de lujo ya quedaron coloreadas
cuatro de estas cinco partes en las que
habían dividido el entero pero ahora
quiero tomarme dos terceras partes lo
que quiere decir que voy a dividir ahora
a este entero en tres partes
en tres partes para tomarme en dos
terceras partes de estos cuatro quintos
y lo voy a dividir en tres partes justo
así imagínate que esta es un tercio así
que lo voy a poner justo por aquí ok y
por acá hasta el otro tercio a más o
menos un poquito más arriba por acá aquí
tengo el otro tercio
estoy dividiendo a está entero ahora en
tres partes iguales una dos y tres pero
de manera horizontal y bueno ahora si me
quiero tomar de estos cuatro quintos dos
terceras partes lo que podemos obtener
de una manera muy rápida es tomar la
herramienta del color es más déjame
ponerlo ahora ahora con líneas para que
lo veas más claro me voy a tomar una ok
una una de estas terceras partes una de
estas terceras partes y me voy a fijar
solamente en la parte que estaba
coloreada y dos terceras partes
2 ok dos terceras partes la otra tercera
parte coloreada o no coloreada no la voy
a poner con color azul porque date
cuenta que solamente quiero dos tercios
por cuatro quintos me voy a tomar dos
terceras partes de cuatro quintos y si
te das cuenta ahora podemos ver cuántos
cuadritos quedaron coloreados así que
vamos a contarlos me quedo con 1 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 estoy tomándome 8 de estas 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 de estas 15 partes por lo
tanto si yo me quiero tomar dos tercios
por cuatro quintos mi resultado debería
de ser 2 por 48 son 8 partes las que
tengo ahora coloreadas de azul entre las
15 partes totales que me quedaron entre
las 15 partes totales que me quedaron de
una manera aritmética podemos corroborar
que 2 x 4 es 8 3 por 5 es 15 815 ambos
van a ser la cantidad de cuadritos que
quedaron color
de estos 15 que tengo aquí